andrea is with us in tampa florida
hi Andrea how are you hi Dave I'm great
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up so my husband and I went
through a few about two years ago and we
are on baby step six and we're having a
little disagreement over something he
wants to purchase so we figured you'd be
the tiebreaker yeah I'll get my striped
shirt and whistle out I'll be the
referee awesome thank you so our
household incomes about 120 from our
regular you know jobs that we do he just
started a side business which is
basically doing online marketing and
right now he's making about forty three
hundred a month with it so yeah it went
really well yeah um his expenses are
very minimal so it's probably at least
thirty five hundred a month in profit
yeah excellent yeah it's doing well but
it's still a really new business he's
only been doing it for about two months
um and he has right now three clients
and he's hoping to get a few more but
he's very excited about this and wants
to purchase a fairly expensive fifteen
hundred dollar piece of exercise
equipment I'm out of the business and
I'm just nervous because it's still a
new business and I'd rather we kind of
just save up and plan for it the way we
do with everything else in our normal
household budget but just want to get
your thoughts okay well he's not really
buying it for the business or out of
business it's out of your household
income which now has an extra eight
thousand dollars in it or frum few
months of work even Karaka so let's just
pretend he was at work and he got a
bonus for $8,000 mm-hmm
maybe there's a one-time bonus cane okay
just for the fun of it that's like your
worst case scenario meaning he's already
made $8,000 on the online business two
months and four grand right yes okay and
so if he never made another dime it
would be like you got a nice bonus at
work
$8,000 yeah and how did that check you
want to buy $1,500 piece of equipment
mm-hmm would that be bad I don't know I
guess I would just rather I'm just
excited about paying off the house okay
now that's a fair argument because I
miss that you get a bonus in and we say
do we want to supply if we can change
how the money came in but we got some
extra money is what it amounts to
okay and you want to throw it at the
house and he wants to buy this piece of
equipment yes okay and how much is a
balance on your home right now we all
about 150 done all right and have you
guys not done anything else to enjoy it
some money since you busted through baby
step three we have we've taken some nice
vacation when we always set money aside
for travel so we definitely have yeah
good I'm glad you did
that's because look because what we
teach as you know and it sounds like
you're living that properly is to have
gazelle intensity which is scorched
earth no life at all till you get
through baby step three and then when
you get through baby step three you let
your foot off the gas a little bit and
you're just concentrate but you buy some
things and enjoy some things while
continuing to pay extra on the house
which is what you did when you went on
the trip right yes mm-hmm and that's
also what this exercise equipment is I
suppose it is mm-hmm it is
I mean it's if you want to move up in
car it'd be the same argument if you
wanted to you know you're driving a
$5,000 car and you want to move to a
$8,000 car and you want to you know move
up spend the extra three grand on that
and something like that that'd be the
same discussion is that's going to eat
up just like the trip ate up some of the
money that could have gone towards the
house but the point is that's the the
letting off of the accelerator backing
off from full-on gazelle intensity to
you know enjoying and doing some other
stuff you might even increase some
giving during that time and all those
kinds of things so the point is to be
concentrating on the house but not to
the exclusion of all other things so
really the truth is what this argument
comes down to is
this is not a joint purchase that both
of you are want it's something he just
wants basically yeah that's a-ok it's
not that it's the wrong places it's not
that it's the wrong place in the baby
steps or that it's really against the
house it's just he wants it and you
don't care about one way or the other
yeah and I kind of feel like we should
maybe just it feels like an impulse a
little bit like maybe we should have
saved up for you know five hundred lies
a month or something because I don't
know I just feel like it's a little
impulsive and it's more you got money
you donate those not a bonus and you can
say you know we want to do some giving
or whatever um so you know what like
what you could do to that that's a fair
argument too it's a fair part of the
equation
sometimes when Sharon and I are talking
about it she's like I don't know kind of
feels like you just got the fever let's
wait a month and see if you still want
it after a month if you still want it
we'll do it okay and see if the fever
goes away that would change it from an
impulse to a solid purchase what kind of
piece what kind of exercise equipment is
it um it's one of these peloton spin
bike okay all right yeah
and it's exciting spinning is clean yes
huge fun how long as you're gonna focus
too much a couple of years okay so him
being on him being on a bike is not an
impulse correct
okay I mean just I've never taken spin
class so me buying one might be more of
a more of a runner you know and that
kind of thing so maybe on one might be
more of an impulse because it's not it's
not like it's something he's never done
is my point
that's correct and that's that's an
argument for him so yeah I might shop
around try to figure out where we can
pick one up used at one of the sports
consignment stores or Craigslist or
something like that is there a place to
find one a you know really nice one but
slightly used is somebody using to hang
their clothes on instead of actually
ride and that kind of stuff and you know
let's take a month and and see if he
cools off on it if after a month we find
a bargain
and or he still wants it I'd probably do
it
he wins okay well thanks he's going to
be really happy to hear that but you see
how I got there
I do it makes sense yes yeah it's
there's nothing in here about you guys
being here responsible the reason I
walked all the way through that is it's
good it's a good exercise all for our
listeners too to just think through
properly to think through at that baby
step where you're trying to pound the
house okay when do we stop pay on the
house and when to do we pay on the house
because if all you do is buy stuff
you'll never pay on the house and that's
your point but I don't think you guys
are out of control the fact that you're
having this discussion is proof that you
are in control so that's pretty cool I
think you're going to get the house paid
off pretty quick by the way and and I
think it's going to be due to his
business exploding because I got a
feeling this 40,000 will turn into
80,000 and that's probably going to pay
the house off so I think we're okay
that's the other part that's rattling
around in the back of my head here
that's a cool discussion it really is
it's a good thing to talk about
you know PJ on Twitter says is there a
balance between gizelle intensity and
what the Bible says the dangers of
gaining wealth hastily well PJ gizelle
intensity doesn't have anything to do
with gaining wealth because ill
intensity has to do with getting out of
that which is from the scriptures and
its power of six one through seven if
you've signed surety my son do this give
no sleep to your eyelids no slumber to
your eyes and deliver yourself like a
gazelle from the hand of the hunter a
bird from the hand of the Fowler
that's proverbs 6 1 through 7 now what's
that mean if you've signed sure it these
Old English Bible talk forgotten
yourself into debt how you get out of
debt you deliver yourself like a gazelle
from the hand of the hunter you run like
a cheetah is chasing you trying to kill
you that's gazelle intensity you run for
your freakin life and that's to get out
of debt that is not a danger of gaining
wealth hastily because we're not trying
to gain wealth we're trying to get away
from the dadgum master because we're a
slave the borrower is slave to the
lender which frees us up to build wealth
as a steady plotting thing because yeah
there is gaining wealth hastily there's
all kinds of warnings about that in
script
and not only your spirit but also just
the general process that you end up
building a house of cards which is what
I did is I went broke
I gained wealth a stoolie in my 20s and
borrowed to that much money and caving
on my head because I was stupid and
that's what it comes down to there are
different things and so the Gazelle
intensity does run up through baby step
3 through the emergency fund and after
that let your foot off the gas now you
start your wealth building now we start
paying off the house and we start
upgrading the couch getting the spin
bike and so forth this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]